eine gallenblasenentfernung oder
polizist economy wird normalerweise
durchgeführt wenn gallen
in der oder eine entzündung der
gallenblase festgestellt wird
die symptome einer gallenblasen
erkrankung die meistens aus zeitweiligen
schmerzen im rechten oberbauch bestehen
treten im allgemeinen auch wenn
gallensteine einen der beiden gänge die
gallenflüssigkeit von der galle in den
darm übertragen vorübergehend blockieren
wenn die steine stecken bleiben kann die
gallenblase anschwellen und sich
entzünden was zu schwerwiegenderen
symptomen wie übelkeit erbrechen und
fieber führen kann
mit neueren laparoskopischen eingriffen
müssen nur noch kleine einschnitte
gemacht werden wodurch die heilungsphase
wesentlich kürzer ist
vor dem eingriff wird ihnen ein
intravenöser schlauch angelegt und sie
erhalten unter umständen ein
beruhigungsmittel zur entspannung
laparoskopische polizisten werden unter
vollnarkose durchgeführt das heißt sie
schlafen während der gesamten operation
dadurch entspannen sich die muskeln in
der bauchdecke und der chirurg die
chirurgen hat ausreichenden arbeitsraum
ein atem schlauch wird vorübergehend in
ihren mund und rachen eingeführt um ihre
atmung während der operation zu
unterstützen
unter umständen wird auch ein gast
rischer schlauch über ihren mund in den
magen eingeführt um marken flüssigkeiten
abzusaugen
in den meisten fällen dauert der
eingriff 30 bis 60 minuten
ihr chirurg ihre chirurgen verwendet
schafe instrumente die sogenannten trug
are um eine reihe von kleinen öffnungen
in ihrer bauchdecke zu schaffen über die
auf die gallenblase und die umliegenden
strukturen zugriff genommen werden kann
eine dieser öffnungen ist normalerweise
der bauchnabel
in einem nächsten schritt wird über den
nabel zugang kohlendioxid gas in ihrem
bauch gepumpt um die strukturen besser
sichtbar zu machen
danach führt der chirurg die chirurgen
über den nabel zugang das laparoskopie
die bilder der geräte kamera werden im
op saal auf einen videobildschirm
projiziert mit anderen instrumenten die
ebenfalls über portale eingeführt werden
erfasst der chirurg die chirurgen die
gallenblase schneidet die haupt arterie
und den gang ablegt die plaza in einen
speziellen beutel und zieht diesen durch
einen der zugänge heraus vor dem
entfernen des laparoskopie untersucht
der chirurg die operation stelle noch
einmal genau auf blutungen oder andere
schäden
nach dem entfernen des laparoskopie wird
kurzzeitig ein ventil angelegt damit das
kohlendioxid aus der bauchhöhle
entweichen kann
danach werden die kleinen einschnitte
mit nähten oder klammern geschlossen und
es wird ein verband angelegt
nach der operation wird der atem und
magen schlauch herausgezogen und sie
kommen zur überwachung in einen
aufwachraum
dort erhalten sie gegebenenfalls
schmerzmittel und werden langsam von
flüssiger nahrung auf weich kost und
fest kost umgestellt die intravenösen
schläuche werden abgenommen sobald ihr
magen darm trakt ausgeheilt ist
die meisten kohle zusteckt omi patienten
verlassen das krankenhaus innerhalb von
24 stunden nur bei patienten mit
entzündeten gallenblasen kann ein
krankenhaus aufenthalt von ein bis zwei
tagen erforderlich sein